as an Arctic blast grips much of the
United States hospitalizations for
Respiratory illnesses like covid are on
the rise in more than 30 States we're
all back on the trains and the buses so
we're back to face to- face contact so
yeah people are getting sick yeah I
would say Co is more or less a concern
along with influenza and RSV death rates
have ticked up too though they do remain
far below the covid pandemic Peak the
trend is the same in Europe and other
parts of the world world we still have
around 10,000 deaths per month and
that's only data from 50 countries among
those 10,000 deaths reported in December
more than half were reported from the
United States of America a thousand from
Italy fewer than 20% of American adults
have received the latest covid vaccine
however I didn't get this latest one
because I heard that is making people
sick and everything Health officials
warn that puts vulnerable individuals
and Health Care Systems at risk here in
New York once the epicenter of the covid
pandemic in the United States mask
mandates have been reinstated inside
public hospitals and for medical First
Responders an attempt to slow the
virus's
transmission New York has also launched
a study of 10,000 people to better
understand CO's long-term impact on the
body we have a lot of evidence that uh
Co affects number a number of our
systems whether it's your endocrine
system your heart and your lungs your
brain your blood vessels um but we don't
know what the long-term implications of
that and longitudinal cohort studies
like this one um have been effective
over time as doctors try to understand
the true impact of long-term covid one
thing is certain caution is still needed
to keep the vulnerable safe Kristen
salumi Al jazer New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer